ja liebe freunde auch von meiner seite
noch einmal herz zu bekommen hier in der
landeshauptstadt sachsens in dresden im
wunderschönen dresden begrüßt die ganze
hat sich nochmal für diesen
bundesparteitag möchte mich auch bei
meinen vorrednern j&j wollten bedanken
für die gute worte und für die
dankesworte ich möchte mich aber auch
hier nochmal für alle helfer bedanken
die diesen wunder prächtigen und schönen
gestalteten parteitag möglich gemacht
haben möchte mich auch bei der polizei
bedanken die untaugliche diesem
parteitag abgesichert hat also auch das
gehört denke ich dazu dass wir uns bei
diesen ganzen helfern bedanken
ja liebe freunde auf dem parteitag von
kalkar haben wir erfolgreich unsere
renten und sozialkonzept verabschiedet
damit google eine programmatische lücke
geschlossen
was ist nun der nächste schritt was
heute passieren
wir freuen heute werden wir geschichte
schreiben dieser bundesparteitag wird
als der dresdner in erinnerung bleiben
denn heute geht es nicht um weniger als
um den aufbruch für deutschland und hier
liebe freunde wir gemeinsam werden die
zukunft gestalten wir befinden uns
mitten im superwahljahr 2021 und wir
haben es in der hand die wahlen die wahl
in den baden württemberg und rheinland
pfalz haben uns gelehrt dass wir
geschlossen zueinander stehen und
miteinander mutig nach vorn schreiten
müssen
sie haben uns gelehrt wir brauchen ein
klares profil
wir brauchen einigkeit mut und
entschlossenheit
nur so können wir in den wahlen bestehen
und erfolgreicher werden
wir müssen zeigen wofür wir wir alle
gemeinsam stehen hier auf dem parteitag
und auch im wahlkampf von hier aus muss
das signal ausgehen an alle mitstreiter
für unsere gute sache in den
landesverbänden aber auch in den kreisen
und die innerparteilichen kleinkrieg in
der letzten monate sind wasser auf die
mühlen unserer politischen gegner
sie mussten sich nicht einmal mühe geben
oder sich anstrengen das haben einige
von uns schon selbst erledigt und nicht
wenige haben sich davon auch irritieren
lassen und jörg menten hatte ja recht
als er in seiner rede in kalkar mehr
disziplin ein forderte aber diese
disziplin muss für alle gelten und zwar
von einzelnen mitglied bis zu dem bundes
vorstandsmitgliedern
brück liebevollen mehr
und liebe freunde natürlich muss auch
einen bundessprecher seine gedanken über
den zustand der partei äußern und den
finger in die wunde legen aber bestimmte
dinge sollten intern und nicht in der
öffentlichkeit diskutiert werden wir als
bundesvorstand müssen allerdings auch
über die fähigkeit und die größe
verfügen und in bestimmten
entscheidenden situationen vor unsere
mitglieder zu stellen
dafür wurden wir schließlich auch
gewählt
und deshalb liebe freunde fordere ich
euch heute hier auf diesem parteitag auf
schluss mit dem lagerdenken schluss mit
den scheren und schranken im kopf
jetzt ist schluss damit es reicht wir
müssen und haben nicht mehr viel zeit
und sollten die energie dafür aufbringen
für unser land das ist wichtig und ganz
ehrlich ich hab es mittlerweile auch ein
stückweit satt dass man sich hier in
unserer partei dazu erklären muss warum
man sich wann und mit wem getroffen oder
gesprochen hat auch das ist jetzt so
einen teil zum guten stunde worden ich
treffe mich ganz ehrlich ich treffe mich
mit frau von storch ich treffe mich mit
alexander downer hand ich treffe mich
mit böcker ich treffe mich mit christine
brinker ich treffe mich mit
cdu-mitgliedern mit fdp-mitgliedern ich
rede mit kommunisten ich wähle mit
kabarettisten ich treffe mich auch mit
außenministern und ich frage euch gibt
es wirklich schon wieder bei uns eine
gewisse kontakte schuld der wird von
geheimtreffen gesprochen
da wird von geheimtreffen gesprochen wo
die medien natürlich auch angebracht
werden dabei ist das für mich das
natürlichste der welt und übrigens bei
diesen geheimtreffen waren 50 weitere
dabei die sogenannte geheimen treffen
und stellt euch vor es gab sogar
gulaschsuppe dort und stellt euch noch
etwas vor es gab auch schwarzbrot was
man dort essen konnte es ist doch die
aufgabe und auch die pflicht als
bundessprecher verschiedene und
unterschiedliche menschen innerhalb und
außerhalb unserer partei anzusprechen
verbindung zu halten und kontakte
aufzubauen
von uns erwartet man dass wir die ziele
der partei formulieren dass wir die
partei führen und das mit gutem recht
und das ist richtig regelmäßig in
klausur zu gehen die eigene position
auszutauschen und auch kontrovers zu
streiten diese diskurse müssen wir
pflegen und ausbauen
denn das ist unser markenzeichen das ist
es was unsere partei auszeichnet und uns
von den altparteien unterscheidet es ist
doch gerade die unterschiedlichen
meinungen und positionen die unsere
partei groß gemacht haben
diese freunde und das sind genau unsere
stärken und ich will dass das wir alle
egal in welcher funktion und position in
der partei das leben und auch mit leben
erfüllen wir die alternative für
deutschland haben die mut und die kraft
dazu wir sind aufgestanden und stellen
uns gegen die destruktive politik der
ehemaligen großparteien diese arbeiten
seit langem gegen unser land und gegen
die interessen der menschen mir freunde
dieses deutschland braucht eine
alternative und die sind wir
vor uns liegen richtige tage und wochen
von landtagswahlen bis hin zu den wahlen
zum 20
deutschen bundestag am 20 26 september
wir haben in den vergangenen vier jahren
eine gute und zuverlässige arbeit
geleistet die fraktion der afd im
deutschen bundestag kann stolz sein
darauf wie sie ihre legislatur
gemeistert hat und ich möchte mich hier
an dieser stelle bei allen abgeordneten
der bundestagsfraktion bedanken auch für
diejenigen die eventuell ausscheiden
oder dem nicht mehr antreten wir können
wirklich stolz sein wir haben ein gutes
fundament aufgebaut und wir sollten uns
das nicht schlecht reden lassen
und dass man jetzt immer besser machen
kann ist klar
das werden wir in der nächsten
legislaturperiode auch unter beweis
stellen selbst etablierte parteien mit
jahrzehnten parlamentserfahrung sind
nicht perfekt vielmehr haben die
altparteien längst ihren kompass
verloren wir sehen uns ja jeden tag wenn
wir alleine uns die korruptions- und
spendenaffäre der cdu anschauen liebe
freunde das müssen wir der bevölkerung
auch vor augen führen
allerdings warne ich auch davor sich
allzu sehr von über moral leiten zu
lassen
fehler passieren auch bei uns und fehler
sind menschlich
wir sollten unsere zeit für deutschland
aufwenden und uns nicht als politischen
hetzkampagnen abarbeiten wir müssen
zeigen wofür wir stehen und wofür wir
arbeiten deshalb sind wir heute auch
hier dass wir es können und wollen zeigt
die neue kampagne zum
bundestagswahlkampf wir werben mit
klaren formen aussagekräftigen bildern
und auch einer leitidee deutschland aber
normal
was meinen sie damit zunächst eine kurze
bestandsaufnahme wo stehen wir heute
wie steht deutschland 2021 da und ich
sage es euch kurz und präzise
wenn wir alle wissen doch was schief
läuft die politik der vergangenen 16
jahre hat deutschland an die wand
gefahren wirtschaftlich sozial kulturell
und politisch 30 jahre nach der
deutschen wiedervereinigung es ist
wieder opportun die grundrechte der
menschen einzuschränken 72 jahre nach
der geburt unseres grundgesetzes setzt
eine deutsche regierung die freiheit der
menschen aufs spiel
unsere freiheit für die gerade wir hier
in den neuen bundesländern gestritten
haben für die wir hier auf die straße
gegangen sind das werden wir nicht
dulden und zu lassen
wir wollen
wir wollen in freiheit sicherheit und
wohlstand leben
es darf nicht sein dass die einkommen in
deutschland nur noch für weniger
auskömmlich sind und vor allem für eine
sichere und menschenwürdige
altersvorsorge nicht mehr ausreichen
werden es darf nicht sein dass ich
wieder ideologie über menschen erlebt es
darf nicht sein dass politik und
politiker nicht mehr das gemeinwohl der
menschen im blick haben
auch das war ein grund warum wir uns
2013 gegründet haben das maß war voll
die enttäuschung über die zustände
schlug in den villen um das land wieder
aktiv auf den richtigen kurs zu bringen
von der wahnwitzigen euro-politik der
vollkommen fehl geleiteten
migrationspolitik 2015 oder der
ideologisch belasteten energie und
umweltpolitik alles beispiele für eine
abgehobene und menschenfeindliche
klientel politik die wir nicht länger
hinnehmen werden all diese
entscheidungen und viele entscheidungen
wurden bis heute nicht korrigiert und
zurückgenommen
und genau deswegen gibt es uns und
deshalb sind wir heute hier ihr alle
kennt eure heimat und seit mit ihr
verbunden euch liegt eine gesunde heimat
am herzen
ihr könnt die menschen und wisst um die
unterschiedlichen wünsche ihr seid teil
gemeinschaft und genau deswegen wisst
ihr dass es überall in unserem land
besondere herausforderungen gibt und es
gibt liebe freunde das will ich hier
noch einmal besonders hervorheben so
viele unterschiedliche mentalitäten in
deutschland wie es dialekte gibt und auf
diese mentalitäten und dialekte sind wir
stolz
sie sind ausdruck unserer kultur die
wollen wir fliegen und erhalten darüber
sind wir uns einig
und genau dem entspricht unser
leitantrag liebe freunde darin
zementieren wir die wichtigsten
eckpfeiler für die zukunft unserer
heimat und ich will dass wir damit
vorwärtsgehen unaufhaltsam ungehorsam
mit klarem blick
man wirft uns ja immer vor wir wurden
immer nur dagegen sein
viele freunde seit jahren sagen wir wie
es anders gehen würde
wir sind die alternative für deutschland
und wir haben die alternativen lösungen
und konzepte für unser land
ich hatte vorhin die bedeutung eines
klaren profils betont deswegen will ich
jetzt im leitantrag dieses bundes
parteitages kommen ich möchte mich hier
auch an dieser stelle bei allen bedanken
die an diesem beitrag mitgearbeitet
mitgearbeitet und auch zu gearbeitet
haben an die vielen ehrenamtlichen von
landes fachausschüssen bundes
fachausschüssen die und auch der
bundesprogramm kommission die im
hintergrund nicht sichtbar diese arbeit
geleistet haben ich möchte mich auch an
den leiter der bundes programmkommission
albrecht glaser bedanken der das mit
koordiniert hat stellvertretend
natürlich für alle anderen und ich
möchte hier auch aufrufen
dort mitzuwirken hier können gestritten
werden diskutiert werden hier kann jeder
seine erfahrung einbringen
deswegen beteiligt euch daran gute
mitglieder sind dort immer bekommen
bitte macht mit
und genau damit zeigen wir einmal mehr
dass wir politische themenfelder in
einem vernünftigen verhältnis mäßigen
und verantwortungsvollen maß entwickeln
ich will kurz einige prägnante
zusammenhänge darstellen
jeder unternehmer weiß ist braucht
gewisse voraussetzungen dass er in einer
region auch investieren können
dazu gehört die verkehrsinfrastruktur
die energieversorgung und die soziale
sicherung
auch ist klar dass die unterschiedlichen
regionen in deutschland sehr
unterschiedlich entwickelt sind
du bist die grundaufgabe des staates
gleichwertige strukturen im ganzen land
aufzubauen
und genau hier knüpft unser programm ein
wir zeigen den sozialen und
gesellschaftlichen wandel auf wir haben
eine vision für deutschland
und viel wichtiger wir haben auch
konkrete vorschläge wie sie sich
finanzieren lassen
lasst mich drei beispiele anführen damit
beziehe ich mich auf die bereiche
wirtschaft soziales und
regionalentwicklung ganz bewusst betone
ich zusätzlich das arbeitsfeld
gesundheit und damit die
herausforderungen die sich durch corona
für die genannten drei bereiche auch
ergeben
nehmen wir das beispiel einer region in
sachsen noch konkreter meine
heimatregion der oberlausitz hier wird
nämlich exemplarisch deutlich dass mit
dem vorzeitigen und nicht durchdachten
ausstieg aus der kohle energie ein
riesiges defizit für die lokale
wirtschaft entsteht und das wird sich
besonders auf die sozialen bereiche
auswirken
im ergebnis wird auch diese region
entvölkert dass ich für jüngere menschen
kaum entwicklungsmöglichkeiten ergeben
mit diesem beispiel kann ich auch viele
andere regionen deutschlands
charakterisieren
was bleibt also es wird deutlich dass
hier eine spezifische förderung
notwendig ist sonst wandert mit den
menschen auch die wirtschaft ab das
passiert immer wieder
und die politik hat es bislang nicht
geschafft diese selbst gemachten
entwicklungen wieder aufzufangen und
deswegen frage ich euch wollen wir die
menschen noch mehr zumuten nein liebe
freunde und deshalb kommt jetzt unsere
alternative
zunächst müssen wir uns im klaren sein
dass es kaum möglich ist an allen orten
gleichzeitig zu wirken
es braucht spezifische den jeweiligen
bedürfnissen angepasste maßnahmen wir
sprechen hier über eine sogenannte
mutter region und interessanterweise mit
dieser forderung bin ich bereits 2017 in
den bundestagswahlkampf gestartet
damals hieß es noch vom jetzigen noch
amtierenden ministerpräsidenten in
sachsen name fällt mir nicht ein
das sei reiner populismus ist eine
schnapsidee es geht überhaupt nicht und
unmittelbar
jetzt fordert genau diese sächsische cdu
eine sonderwirtschaftszone um die
beschriebenen probleme zu begegnen also
daran erkennt man die heuchelei auch der
cdu was wirklich möglich ist und mit
folgenden konzepten möchte ich die
möchte ich die afg hier mit dieser mail
beschreibung vorantreiben und zwar
abschaffung der co2 steuer dauerhafte
senkung des mehrwertsteuersatzes von 19
auf 15 prozent
eine belastbare infrastruktur besonders
im ländlichen raum auch bäuerliche
landwirtschaftliche familienbetriebe
müssen erhalten und gefördert wegen
nicht durch die industriellen
großbetrieben
dann spricht man ja häufig davon das
kann man nicht finanzieren wo bleiben
die gegen finanzierungsmaßnahmen auch da
haben wir vorschläge
allein durch die kosten der migration
kann man potenzial einsparen senkung der
deutschen beiträge an die europäische
union wir reden hier von der schulden
union die nächsten jahre
750 milliarden euro wahnsinn
die jährlichen zusatzkosten durch den
ausstieg großbritanniens aus der eu
deutschland schultert dabei 13
milliarden zusätzlich dann die ganze
aufgeblähte eu das eu parlament
da kann man locker die hälfte einsparen
dann streichung der mittel für den kampf
gegen die sogenannten klimawandel auch
da sind kosteneinsparungen möglich und
wir können noch nicht immer nur und das
ist auch von mir ein ansatz wir können
doch nicht immer nur über weitere
einnahmen reden sondern müssen uns mal
die ausgaben des staates anschauen und
deshalb braucht es auch einen ehrlichen
kassensturz
und genau damit schafft eine vernünftige
politik die notwendigen
rahmenbedingungen zu dass ich überhaupt
betriebe und unternehmen ansiedeln das
wieder lust auf unternehmertum auf hand
seit sich in deutschland entwickeln das
für familien überhaupt eine
lebensgrundlage geschaffen wird
beispiele sind dafür bildungs betreuungs
gesundheits und pflegeangebot ebenso wie
die möglichkeiten die freizeit zu
gestalten
und ich hatte vorhin das feld der
gesundheit genannt gerade jetzt in den
wirren der korona politik werden die
versäumnisse der letzten jahrzehnte
gnadenlos deutlich eine vernünftige
schulbildung ist nicht mehr möglich
krankenhäuser viel personal oder wurden
sogar geschlossen gerade im ländlichen
raum ebenso im ländlichen raum die
telekommunikation die auf einen stand
ist wie vor 20 jahren und wir werden
mehr und mehr von ausländischen
energieversorgern abhängig dieser
zustand ist nicht mehr erträglich und
für die menschen die tagtäglich arbeiten
und steuern zahlen
auch nicht mehr verständlich nein diese
situation gefährdet auch unser
gemeinschaft und die zukunft unserer
gesellschaft wir brauchen pragmatische
lösung anstelle ständig neuer ideologien
von grün schwarz roten kobolden liebe
landsleute ihr seht es warum deutschland
die ard braucht
und dieser leitantrag zeigt wir haben
vernünftige konzepte und ideen für unser
land schon jetzt streiten wir auf
kommunal- landes- und bundesebene mit
den mitteln der parlamentarischen
demokratie in unzähligen anträgen
anfragen durch initiativen und die
ausschöpfung von rechtsmitteln bringen
wir unsere lösungsvorschläge in den
politischen diskurs ein
die erfahrungen der letzten jahre haben
uns nach vorn gebracht wir sind als
partei gestartet die als einzige den
protest der bevölkerung wahrgenommen hat
und wahrnimmt
wir sind und bleiben die stimme des
volkes und wir werden uns nicht an diese
politik anpassen
wir entwickeln uns immer weiter und wir
bleiben auch nicht stehen
die alternative für deutschland bietet
einen weg fern jeder rechten oder linken
ideologischen verblendung
das sind nicht unsere kategorien mit
denen wir die zukunft gestalten können
ich will euch die potenziale aufzeigen
die in uns in unserem programm stecken
wir blicken über den tellerrand
überkommener gesellschaftlicher
sichtweisen hinaus wir betreiben keine
klientel politik für oder gegen jemanden
so haben die regierung unser land bis
jetzt nämlich an die wand gefahren
wir wissen dass jeder teil unseres
landes einzigartig ist dass jede region
ihre eigenen anforderungen und
bedürfnisse hat die müssen durch die
politik nur aufgenommen werden deshalb
stehen wir für alle menschen die an der
wertschöpfung deutschlands beteiligt
sind beteiligt waren und beteiligt sein
werden egal wo sie leben ost west nord
süd in der stadt oder auf dem land egal
welche kategorien bildung religion
soziale herkunft hautfarbe geschlecht
und so weiter vollkommen egal wir
definieren uns als volkspartei und das
nicht nur über bloße zahlen
wir verstehen uns als volkspartei weil
wir ein profil entwickelt haben mit dem
wir alle menschen erreichen
wir sind eine innovative partei
und innovation haben bindekräfte aus der
gegenwart mit den erfahrungen der
vergangenheit in die zukunft hinein
liebe freunde ich will euch das an
folgendem beispiel deutlich machen was
ich damit auch meine wir sind die
einzige partei die nicht nur über die
alterspyramide redet sondern auch den
teil unserer bevölkerung wahrnimmt und
wertschätzt den wir die grundlagen
unseres wohlstands und unserer sozialen
sicherheit verdanken unseren älteren
mitmenschen und ich will hier noch
einmal an unser konzept zur renten und
sozialpolitik erinnern
und wir wissen vor welchen
herausforderungen wir stehen die
sozialen sicherungssysteme sind
integraler bestandteil deutschlands und
ausdruck der sozialen marktwirtschaft
und das sollen sie auch bleiben
allerdings geht das nicht ohne
veränderung und diese dürfen nicht zu
lasten der jüngeren und jüngsten gehen
sozial bedeutet dass diejenigen die ihr
ganzes arbeitsleben lang zur
wertschöpfung beigetragen haben auch im
alter eine auskömmliche rente bekommen
müssen bildung
bildung und entwicklungschancen für
nachfolgende generationen gibt es nicht
zum nulltarif
sie sind die grundvoraussetzung dass
deutschland der weltweit bekannte und
zuverlässige technologie führer bleibt
und vielmehr auch wieder wird damit wir
damit erfolgreich sein können muss der
staat so viel absicherung wie nötig und
so viel freiheit wie möglich bieten und
liebe freunde ich habe ja vorhin die
bestattung der ländlichen region
hervorgehoben
gerade hier liegt so viel ungenutztes
potenzial hier leben die menschen die
eine sehr hohe verbundenheit zu ihrer
heimat und ihrer familie haben
es handelt sich in den führenden
industrienationen förmlich hat sich für
mich ein gerüstet dass die qualität der
einzelnen arbeitskraft an deren
flexibilität gemessen wird warum ist es
gewünscht gut oder normal dass man erst
mal seine region verlassen muss um
beruflich erfolgreich zu sein
natürlich kann es nicht überall die
gleichen industrien geben aber war es
nicht so dass man nach den gesellen
jahren wieder in die heimat zurückkehren
konnte um dort an der wertschöpfung der
region mitzuwirken und hier sehe ich die
aufgabe der politik bislang ging man
davon aus das ist wirtschaftlicher
leuchttürme und ballungszentren geben
muss aber zu welchem preis
ganze landstriche veröden und werden
danach mit öffentlichen geldern wieder
fit gemacht in form von
tourismusgebieten oder wie zuletzt in
sachsen in meiner heimatregion
oberlausitz beschlossen
durch die stationierung der bundeswehr
also alle staatsgelder die einzelne
region offensichtlich nicht nachhaltig
unterstützen und so treibt man die
systematische verarmung und auch die
gesellschaftliche spaltung erst mal ran
immer noch werden die menschen dafür
bestraft wenn sie sich zu ihrer
heimatregion bekennen so darf das nicht
weitergehen
die politischen ideologen
die politischen ideologen der grünen
gaukeln die menschen umweltschutz und
klimarettung vor
aber das thema naturschutz gab es schon
lange vor den grünen ideologien bei
denen der strom ja nur aus der steckdose
kommt nachhaltiges wirtschaften geht nur
mit vernunft und
gesamtgesellschaftlichen
verantwortungsgefühl und das bedeutet
regionale grundversorgung kurze liefer
und arbeitswege und unabhängige
energieversorgung und das setzt voraus
wir müssen ganz bewusst hier und heute
gestalten in der gegenwart
dafür müssen wir die möglichkeiten
endlich wieder erkennen und die noch
vorhandenen freiheiten nutzen
wir müssen mutig fleißig diszipliniert
und zielstrebig sein ja das sind
deutsche tugenden tja das ist ein stück
leitkultur schluss mit dem zögerlichen
verharren politik muss wieder
kurzfristig wirken
verantwortungsbewusste entscheidungen
dürfen nicht ständig auf die lange bank
geschoben werden die menschen sind es
leid sich andauernd vertrösten zu lassen
sie wollen sichtbare ergebnisse nur dann
kann es auch für unsere kinder für
unsere zukunft ein auskömmliches und
sicheres leben in deutschland geben
die menschen wollen sicherheit sie
wollen dass vernunft und der gesunde
menschenverstand regieren
deswegen auch unser motto deutschland
aber normal und wir liebe freunde wir
verkörpern und stehen für vernunft
verantwortung und für ein
verantwortungsbewusstes handeln und
entscheiden
unser moralischer kompass unser festes
fundament basiert auf unsere heimat
unsere verbundenheit mit unserer natur
und unsere heimat eintreten für die
natur sind die grundpfeiler für unsere
sichere und für eine sichere zukunft mit
unseren willen und der notwendigen
energie werden wir unsere heimat die
natur und unsere lebensgrundlagen
schützen
die sicherheit
und auch die tiefste überzeugung und
leidenschaft mit der ich das hier alles
vorträge und vertrete basiert auf
unserer gemeinschaft wie erleben sie
alle in der familie mit freunden und
bekannten so wie hier in alternativen
für deutschland dieser
gemeinschaftsgedanke ist grundlegend für
eine gesellschaft er trägt sie ohne ihn
würden die gesellschaften zerfallen und
mit ihr auch der staat deshalb brauchen
wir das zusammenwirken von heimat
naturschutz und gemeinschaft die heimat
ist etwas sehr persönliches und auch
privates dieses gefühl von geborgenheit
und nestwärme tragen wir alle in uns wir
sehen uns danach ein gutes und sicheres
leben zu führen und wir haben ein recht
darauf unsere gesellschaft braucht
diesen zusammenhalt dafür stehen wir als
alternative für deutschland das ist
unser angebot an deutschland das ist
unsere vision
und ich weiß liebe freunde das vertretet
ihr dafür steht ihr die erlebtes jeden
tag privat und auch als politische
person und das lebe ich auch mit ganzem
herzen und deshalb liebe freunde will
ich hier und heute die menschen in
unserer partei und auch außerhalb
unserer partei ansprechen
ich will euch hier und heute ein
versprechen abgeben
ich werde dafür arbeiten und kämpfen
dass alle menschen die unsere werte
teilen dass alle menschen für die
gemeinschaft heimat und der naturschutz
fundamentale werte sind auf denen sie
ihr leben und das ihrer kinder aufbauen
und gestalten dass diese menschen eine
starke stimme bekommen und ich werde
dafür arbeiten und kämpfen dass alle die
noch wankelmütig sind dass alle die eine
politische heimat suchen mit unserer
partei eine vernünftige alternative
bekommen
[Gelächter]
und ich will dass wir gemeinsam die hand
ausstrecken und die menschen in unserem
land den weg in die zukunft weisen
wir sind für euch da wir sind eure
stimme für eure zukunft und die ihrer
kinder und enkel und ich will denen die
unsere werte nicht teilen
ganz klar sagen feinde unserer
demokratie und unserer verfassung haben
kein platz in deutschland denn wir sind
patrioten
wir sind patrioten wir lieben
deutschland und wir arbeiten daran dass
es lebenswert bleibt liebe freunde
kämpft mit mir für eine bessere zukunft
für unser deutschland in diesem sinne
afd aufbruch für deutschland alternative
für deutschland vielen dank